[Music]
welcome back to cbs morning's the fences
and the checkpoints put up after last
year's assault on the capitol they've
been brought back for tonight stated the
union address it's all part of a series
of safety precautions inside and outside
of the capitol scott mcfarland is along
the fence line on the national mall just
west of the capitol with more on this
part of the story scott good morning to
you
gail good morning to you this tall black
fencing surrounds the capitol complex
this morning this is the same fencing we
saw in the days and weeks after january
6 20 21. capitol police tell us this is
temporary it's here in light of the
state of the union address but also due
to planned protests and trucker convoys
over the next couple of days there will
be road blockades throughout this area
tonight that's customary but this year
there are hundreds of national guard
members helping and activated to support
traffic control that's what's happening
outside inside different safety
precautions this year due to covin
all members inside the house chamber
tonight will have to wear
or are recommended to wear a mask they
will have to take a test to covet test
and test negative what's more no guests
allowed inside the house chamber tonight
members of congress can't bring somebody
with them all in all just a different
look this year more socially distanced
inside the house chamber tony an
untraditional look for sure for what is
an american tradition the state of the
union address
yeah i hope the fencing doesn't become
an american tradition either scott thank
you very much appreciate it